And sexual selection is no joke.
It could be the primary thing.
It's certainly one of the primary
things that's driven human evolution.
And I think you can say that
you think about the environment again,
let's think about the environment.
So you have a dominance hierarchy
and that's really an old structure.
The dominance is harkeys 300 million
years old because it emerged pretty much
whenever there was,
whenever there was a nervous system,
emergent nervous system,
and whenever animals had
occupied the same territory,
they automatically organize themselves
into something approximating a dominance
hierarchy.
So it's a very,
very,
very old structure.
It's older than trees,
it's older than flowers,
it's old.
And as far as real goes,
from a Darwinian sense,
permanent is real.
And so when you,
you can say,
well,
you know,
our burial ancestors adapted
themselves to treats.
And so the tree was a long,
around long enough to be a
feature of the environment.
But the dominance hierarchy has
been around a lot longer than trees.
And you can think of the dominance
hierarchy both as an adaptation to the
environment,
because you'd kind of think about the
dominant Turkey has a cultural construct,
but if a cultural construct
lasts long enough,
then it becomes part of the environment.
And so the dominant Turkey's
part of the environment.
And what seems to happen roughly speaking,
and this is an oversimplification,
but we'll go with it,
is that males have a dominance hierarchy
and there's a relatively small number
of males that are relatively successful.
And those successful males have
preferential access to female reproductive
capacity,
either because of the females actively
choose the more dominant males,
which is very,
very common.
Or because the more dominant males chase
all the less dominant males away so
that even if the females
don't exercise choice,
which they often do,
then the only males left around that can
serve as reasonable mating partners are
the more powerful ones.
And so you think you got to really
radical determiners of evolution as a
consequence of that one?
Is that
each,
I'm not talking about female
dominance hierarchies at the moment,
but I can talk about that.
But that's why this is
an oversimplification,
but what happens is that
the males obviously are
selected for their ability to
move up dominance hierarchies obviously
because the ones that are at the top of
the dominance hierarchy
reproduce preferentially.
And so that means the male dominance
hierarchy becomes a method of selection.
But then allied with that is the female
proclivity for choice on whatever
dimension the dominance
hierarchy happens to be arranged.
And so then female sexual selection also
becomes a radical nonrandom selector
of,
of what,
what genetic material is to
move into the next generation.
And so I,
I fail to see how any of that can be
separated from the emergence of complex
nervous systems and mind over the course
of evolution because people aren't,
creatures aren't making random choices,
they're not random at all.
So we even notice it.
Such things like managing
the Peacock's tail,
you know,
and it's covered with eyes,
which is quite interesting because eyes
of course attract attention and lots of
animals have evolved.
I light markings like Moss,
there's moss that when
they unfold their wings,
they have two big eyes
on the back of them.
And that's to keep birds from eating them.
Right?
Cause the birds don't
like being stared at.
So they stay away from the moths.
But so a peacock's tail
is nothing but eyes.
And so it's very attractive and it
shimmers and there's something about it
that's beautiful,
which is quite interesting to the females
have obviously been selecting the male
peacock peacocks for beauty.
They have this insane tail while so they,
evolutionary biologists have thought,
well what possible utility
could that tail be?
Is it just maybe the females
got fixated on tail so to speak.
And you know,
you got a Baldwin effect loop going there
and the male peacocks just got bigger
and bigger tales and it's just
like an evolutionary dead end.
It's,
you know,
it's a positive feedback list
system that's gone out of control.
But they have done things that
like look at the symmetry and,
and,
and breadth say,
or the symmetry and size and overall
quality of the male peacock's tail as a
marker for physical health.
So reduce parasite load for example.
And it does turn out that the healthier
male peacocks have better tail display.
And so the way,
what the females seem to be doing is using
some marker or some set of markers as
a proxy indicator for,
for,
for health.
And I think,
I think you could say with,
with reasonable,
you could say reasonable that reasonably
that female human beings do the same
thing to male human beings.
And there's some of that vice versa too.
Like we evaluate each other,
for example,
for symmetry,
which is one of the elements of beauty
because healthier people tend to be more
symmetrical and lots of
animals use symmetry.
Butterflies if butterflies won't
mate with another butterfly,
if it deviates from symmetry
by the tiniest amounts,
you can imagine.
So symmetry is a marker and there's other
markers like shoulder width to waste
with his wanton waste,
with to hip with this is another,
that's usually what males use
that to evaluate females in park.
So there's lots of markers of health.
Um,
but it also looks to me like the,
the,
the data worldwide seems
to indicate that women,
so managing that women May to
cross dominance hierarchies and up
socioeconomically speaking and
on average across cultures,
women go for men who are about
four to five years older.
You know,
it varies.
In the Scandinavian countries
that's shrunk a little bit,
but not that much.
And in other cultures it's bigger.
I would say that depends to some degree
on difficulty of establishing economic
independence,
right?
Because in richer countries it's easier
to have enough economic independence if
you're a male to B to B are useful
participant in the process of having
children.
Um,
but it doesn't matter cross culturally,
it's still across an op where
man mate across and down,
they don't care much about
socioeconomic status.
It doesn't seem to be part
of their selection method.
Um,
generally speaking.
So,
so I think that part of that is also
that the ability of women to select for
male health,
it's something like that
because it isn't the only that,
because if you're healthy and energetic,
you're much more likely to be successful
because it's very hard to be successful
if you're ill,
obviously.
I mean,
so because the competition
is just too high.
And both,
both genders,
both sexes select each
other for attractiveness,
both select for intelligence,
both at select for personality,
although the different,
there are differences there in
terms of what's what stressed.
But so,
so,
so I think you can derive a couple
of things out of out of this.
And this is where I think
people are different than,
than other animals.
Importantly different is that,
so you imagine that there's
tremendous selection pressure to,
uh,
towards the production,
let's say of man who are good at climbing
male dominance hierarchies or climbing
the male dominance hierarchy.
But the thing that's so interesting
about people is that we've multiplied our
dominance hierarchies.
You know,
if you take an animal that's got a
rather static behavioral pattern,
then there's,
there's the single hierarchy.
Elephant seals are a good example of that.
So elephant seals,
the males are absolutely massive.
They're way,
way bigger than the females.
And they basically have
harems roughly speaking,
and they use physical prowess as
their marker of status essentially.
And obviously size is a huge part of
that because otherwise the male elephant
seals wouldn't be as,
they're massive.
These things are absolutely enormous.
And so it's just power slash health,
you know,
maybe aggression,
something like that.
It's whatever makes them more um,
suitable for the kind of physical
combat that elephant seals engage it.
So,
and the degree to which
power is associated with
dominance status in those sorts
of situations seems to be associated
with the size differential between males
and females.
So the more power is an issue
with regards to male competence,
the larger the bales are compared to the
females and the more likely the males
are going to have a harem
relationship with the females.
And you see that a little bit in human
beings because men are bigger than women.
They're not overwhelmingly bigger.
That's sexual dimorphism.
And you know,
there's some men that are
smaller than some women,
but on average men are tolerant there.
They have more upper body
strength and so forth.
So there is a power element
to male competition,
but it's not as extended as it
would be among animals say like,
like elephant seals.
So in the elephant seal you see maybe
there's one stable set of traits that's
being selected for that makes the
males more likely to reproduce.
But human beings,
we're very weird creatures because
we're so conceptually flexible.
And so what seems to have happened,
maybe we started males started selecting
each other for don in dominance
competitions for something like cognitive
flexibility and conscientiousness.
It's something like that.
So that would be the ability to abstractly
represent the world and then the
ability operate effectively within it
to represent yourself socially in a way.
And then to carry through with that
because that enables people to trust you.
So it's something like that.
And so that produced cortical expansion
and then women were selecting men who
are good at that and not
produce cortical expansion.
And then there's an arms race
between women and men with regards to
intelligence.
So the women kept up or
they certainly kept up with,
with,
with intelligence as,
as the evolutionary cycle continued.
But one of the consequences of selection
for cortical expansion and increased
cognitive flexibility was that the number
of dominance hierarchies that human
beings could produce started to multiply,
right?
Because there's all sorts of
ways that you can be successful.
There's,
you think about how many ways you can
be successful in a modern culture,
and you can be successful in dimensions
that aren't even associated with each
other.
So you can be successful socially that
that's what an extrovert would do.
You could be successful in
terms of intimate relationships.
That's what a agreeable person would do.
A disagreeable person would be more
successful with regards to competition.
A person who is high in
neuroticism would be,
would be tried to protect themselves and
to establish some sort of security and
open person would be
looking for a flexible,
creative environment.
And so there's this multiplicity of,
of ways that you can establish a dominance
hierarchy and be successful in it.
And if you're creative,
you can come up with your
own damn dominance hierarchy,
which is exactly what you're doing.
If you're creative,
right?
You,
you spin up a game that's
your game and then you,
you make the rules.
And that's hard because if you
make a new game with new rule,
if it's hard to monetize it,
but you can be the best
at playing that game.
And so that's a huge advantage to
being creative if you can pull it off.
So then you think,
well,
what's happened among human beings is
the multiplication of the set of possible
dominance hierarchies.
So it's become very broad.
And then you could say,
well,
what's,
what's driving selection now is the
ability to be successful across multiple
sets of dominance hierarchies.
And that account's at least in
part for our cognitive flexibility.
And so that's really
what a human being is.
A human being is a creature that has high
potential for succeeding across a very
wide range of potential
human dominance hierarchies.
And so that gives us our
transformative psyche.
That's the niche,
that's the niche that we've
both produced and occupy.
And I think it's out of that,
that hero mythology emerges fundamentally
because I think what the hero is,
the mythological hero is a representation
of that part of the psyche that's
particularly good at being successful
across sets of dominance hierarchies.